[Musique]
la situation est inédite
l'assemblée nationale est devenue le 19
juin 2022 plus que jamais le coeur bâton
de notre démocratie le bilan de ces
législatives c'est d'abord une situation
politique tout à fait exceptionnel y a
pas de comparaison avec d'autres
situations politiques sous la vème
république et c'est la chronique d'un
dégagisme qui continue et qui perdure
aussi je dirais qu'on a pour la première
fois en réalité à l'assemblée nationale
eh bien une vision assez exacte du degré
de division et polarisation du pays
c'est ça qui donne ce sentiment de de
chambardement
le président de la république a vaincu à
la présidentielle mais il n'a pas
convaincu aux législatives sans majorité
absolue il ne peut gouverner seul
[Musique]
comment s'est déroulée cette campagne
bloc contre bloc
récit d'une élection qui n'aurait dû
être qu'une formalité
[Musique]
prélude de campagne ce samedi 7 mai 2022
les frères ennemis de la gauche se
retrouvent après des années de brouille
emmanuel macron a été investi pour un
deuxième mandat le matin même à
aubervilliers on sèl l'accord de tous
les partis de gauche avec la naissance
de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale la fameuse nubes
on célèbre un accord dont les
signataires espèrent qu'il fera date
[Musique]
c'est historique vous savez il ya
quelques jours on a fêté l'anniversaire
du front populaire et de cette victoire
aux législatives le 3 mai 36 qui a
ouvert des tas de perspectives la
diminution du temps de travail les
congés payés les gens s'en souviennent
et ce front populaire et bien c'est dans
les pattes ceci que nous inscrivons les
nôtres aujourd'hui voilà donc oui c'est
historique et je pense d'ailleurs ce
n'était pas attendue raison pour
laquelle certains le président en tête
ou un peu la trouille peut-être
les jours précis dont pierre jouve l
ambassadeur du parti socialiste a
négocié avec les émissaires de la france
insoumise pour créer une coalition de
quatre partis
avec la nuit ps la gauche deviendrait
l'adversaire principal de la majorité
présidentielle les négociations ont duré
13 jours et trois nuits rien au regard
des années de défiance
ça fait 15 ans qu'on était dans un moule
politique où on se tapait dessus puis à
france aperçoit qu on parle le même
langage et qu'on a surtout un même
objectif et un même but c'est un changer
la vie des gens et deuxièmement sur tout
et ça je crois que c'est le plus
important construire la gauche que nous
voulons pas celle qu'on nous a apprise
mais celle que nous voulons
là
quelle génération au sein du ps vous
pensez peut-être en tout cas moi que la
délégation ceci risque avec laquelle
nous avons discuté on a appris à se
connaître ta veut pas dire qu'on est
d'accord sur tout mais on a essayé
justement ne pas être empoisonnée j'ai
envie de dire par des vieilles lutte qui
ne nous regardait pas et peut-être que
ça va faciliter les choses
leur programme commun il fondit sur 650
mesures parmi elles trente trois ont été
laissés en suspens faute de consensus
sur l'europe l'otan et le nucléaire on a
laissé nos différences mais aussi nos
accords et qu'en fait la plage colline
que nous allons espaces communs que nous
appelons les médicaments donc c'est pour
ça que rien n'est pas la croix sur tous
les sujets est ce que vous croyez que
entre ceux qui ont défendu la réforme
fillon sur les retraites et sutton
récent du lac sand tours elles sont
parfaitement d'accord qu'ils sont
ensemble c'est emmanuel macron fois vous
nous posez la question à nous pour vous
posez pas la question aux autres il
rassemble des gens qui sont convaincus
que toute leur vie de droite et de
gauche qu'on est tous de gauche evo x
pas normal si c'est normal
cette situation
socialistes écologistes communistes et
insoumis peaufine la photo de famille
après le chèque de la primaire citoyenne
de la campagne présidentielle
ce moment là paraît improbable
jean luc mélenchon a réussi à réunir ce
qui a longtemps été nommés les deux
gauches irréconciliables
comme souvent le leader de la france en
sony se veut lyrique et cite paul eluard
il n'y a pas de hasard
il n'y a que des rendez vous
j'ai assez vécu
et mon expérience
du combat politique me fait mesurer la
profondeur historique
de ce que nous sommes en train de
réaliser je le sais
à ce moment de l'histoire
la lutte est serrée regardée comme une
curiosité politique un peu bancal
une création de jean luc mélenchon
à l'avenir incertain
les électeurs de gauche sont sortis
totalement sonné totalement déboussolée
groggy de l'élection présidentielle le
score de yannick jadot le score d'anne
hidalgo et puis jean luc mélenchon a
fait quelque chose qui est très rare
dans la vie politique en quelques heures
en quelques jours il est arrivé à être
d'une certaine manière quelqu'un qui
change la donne qui change le jeu la
coalition fait que vous prenez le nombre
de députés en 2010 est de gauche
françaises soumises en a 17 regardez
aujourd'hui qu'il ya une progression en
sièges qui est dû à la coalition au fait
d'avoir eu l'intelligence de répondre à
cette aspiration unitaire donc ça c'est
incontestable mais si vous prenez
maintenant en voit le pourcentage de
voix obtenu par l'ensemble de la gauche
aux législatives 2022 par rapport aux
législative 2017 je dis et je redis
qu'il n'y a pas de dynamique qu'il n'y a
pas une expansion forte si la gauche
unie en début de campagne la droite elle
craint les défections quelques candidats
changent de famille politique des
républicains dans l'opposition
deviennent des candidats d' emmanuel
macron constance le grip est de ceux là
sur le terrain elle affronte un candidat
de son ancien parti
c'est au coeur de la très chic
neuilly-sur-seine que se trame cette
histoire d'infidélité
avec une fausse commémoration en forme
de happening à la mémoire de ces députés
perdu pour le parti et une solennité de
rigueur
ne trahiront jamais notre famille nous
ne trahirons jamais l'est républicain
pour une simple petite assiette dessous
la députée perdu pour le parti la voici
constance le grip juste parce qu'on m'a
fait tilt c'est tous ces biens
durables s'ils en venaient à manquer
bah écoute et que dites vous à ceux qui
vit à mouzon ténue je suis toujours
européenne je suis toujours libéral je
sais toujours sociale je suis toujours
républicaine et j'essaie toujours avec
mes convictions sont les mêmes j'ai
choisi de répondre à l'appel au
rassemblement et au dépassement non
c'est parce que l'état parce que je
pense que c'est vous montre où jamais de
se rassembler
dans cette vague de transfuges il y à
aussi eric woerth robin reda et damien
abad qui va mettre nos ministres sur
lesquels j'ai su que j ai fait chez
votre marchand a pas fait pour moi bon
roland voilà l'occasion pourquoi
est elle assume
le lendemain du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle lorsque j'ai
constaté parce que ça a été la position
du bureau politique et le sens des
positionnements des uns et des autres
que la famille politique en réalité
restés dans le ni ni ni macro ni le pen
et comme si les bulletins étaient
équivalents et comme si il fallait voilà
n'est pas à prendre ses responsabilités
pour ne surtout pas un pâté l'avenir ou
auber et l hôtel stratégie de
ceci ou de cela j'avais chaud j'ai
répondu favorablement oui à l'appel au
rassemblement je pense que le moment est
venu de rassembler nos forces et de
faire face un centre de situation
inquiétante la montée des extrêmes
si l'importance des défis que nous avons
à relever tous ensemble
j'ai soutenu l'action et les choses que
je le brûlant les faire présent que je
ne veux pas laisser passer d'accord
bonnes j'avais une décision qu'elle a
prise après avoir eu des conseils des
uns et des autres je ne suis pas du
fameux d'étiquettes je suis une femme
engagée qu'à les convictions des combats
voilà pardon préfère dire les choses
ainsi
j'ai beaucoup discuté avec nicolas
sarkozy oui donc je suis resté très
proche et que je rencontre régulièrement
c'est incontestable nous sommes à 250%
en accord et en phase lui et moi bien
sûr c'est sûr mais face à m bonjour
madame je suis le coup je suis le
candidat des républicains oui il y en a
six oui mais moi je suis le seul
candidat investi par an et si roddick
alors pourquoi est-ce que j'ai bonne
mine parce que ça fait deux mois deux
mois et demi contracte pour constance le
grip qui avait l'investiture des
républiques et ya un mois à dimanche
matin j'organise un tractage tous les
jeunes aient l'air parce qu'il reste des
jaune et vert contrairement à ce qu'on
pense le soir on apprend par la presse
qu'elle rallie la majorité
présidentielle je ne vous raconte pas
comment les gamins ont appris vite la
politique ou plutôt ce que ça ne doit
pas être la politique pour moi elle
s'est déshonoré et elle déshonore la
politique et c'est pour ça que plus
personne que beaucoup de monde s'abstint
aujourd'hui
au niveau national les transfuges entre
l air et la majorité présidentielle ont
été finalement peu nombreux à neuilly
sur seine le candidat ait l'air a été
balayé au premier tour face à la nuque
baisse le changement d'étiquette de
constance le grip ne l'a pas empêché
d'être réélu
[Musique]
ça marchait aussi pour d'autres raisons
qui est qu'en partie l'électorat des
républicains validé aussi au cours du
mandat d' emmanuel macron validé un
rapprochement avec emmanuel macron on
l'avait très bien vu aux élections
européennes les verts n'ont pas su
conserver cette sensibilité pro
européenne pro-business
économique pas obligé par la question
identitaire et comme ne tenait pas un
discours en direction de ses électeurs
lassés de son parti sur emmanuel macron
pendant ce temps là à bas bruit le
rassemblement national fait campagne à
la conquête de l'ouest des terres
traditionnellement à gauche ou le parti
n'a pas de député comme à bien la
gironde
edwige diaz est de toutes les fêtes de
village elias atlantide popularité non
pas rater
impeccable donc là on voyage dans le
temps
[Musique]
il s'agit
en fait parce qu'on a le même âge à peu
près
qu on est blanc de toutes les deux mais
voilà elle attend un bébé elle pas moi
aussi les gens vont voter ça devrait
aller parce qu'on a quand même fait un
très très bon score
au top un peu trop surtout pète un peu
trop sur les scores des extrêmes droites
oui alors qu'on est pas du tout
d'extrême droite quoi
mais sous ses airs faussement naïf
edwige diaz est un véritable animal
politique
depuis des mois el khadri la
circonscription
cobra merci d'abord
savoir ben oui je sais mais bon ils
écoutent bienvenus
elle veut tout maîtriser pour éviter que
face aux journalistes
certains sympathisants paraissent un peu
trop d'extrême droite
et des rentes
il ya beaucoup de cartons connaît pas
tout à fait avec or pendant les
spectacles à cannes
pour vous c'est pas trop ça on l'avait
dit le
monsieur donc si tu peux de charge et on
accueille
je puisse aller voir tout le monde ne
surtout pas casser l'image d'un arn
adoucie bonjour
on peut la faire tout de suite si vous
voulez hein dans certains villages des
alentours plus de 65 % des électeurs ont
voté pour marine le pen à la
présidentielle
maintenant ce qu'on veut c'est gagner
une circonscription dans un scrutin qui
n'a jamais été très favorable au
rassemblement national scrutin
uninominal majoritaire à deux tours
nous nous réclamions la proportionnelle
depuis par nina également depuis
toujours m'apprend l'avait promise en
2010 est il ne l'a pas appliquée vu les
scores qu'on réalise sur le territoire
on peut espérer en effet conquérir un
certain nombre de mairies sur le secteur
dans quatre ans quand mes objets
voilà
ici on se sont un peu perdus dans une
mondialisation devenue incompréhensible
ont subi une augmentation des prix à la
pompe qui sont
liées soi disant guerre qui a lieu
[Musique]
au creux de l'europe pourquoi on n'a
plus de mots tarn pourquoi on a pu
l'huile de tournesol tout ça s'est fait
en ukraine je crois je pose des
questions on a perdu notre pouvoir
d'achat on a perdu nos fleurons
nationaux
nos entreprises
de chômage
ça ça parle à celle où
ça pèse dans la balance
comme beaucoup de français en 2007 j'ai
voté pour sarkozy et puis comme beaucoup
de français j'ai été très déçu par
sarkozy parce que comme beaucoup
j'attendais le travailler plus pour
gagner plus et puis j'attendais le
karcher aussi qui n'a toujours pas été
branché merci beaucoup à 34 ans edwige
diaz et une protégée de marine le pen
[Musique]
jour de blaye
nouveau visage d'un parti qui compte
bien s'implanter là on a jamais personne
ambiance plus bucolique pour veronica
merrer sa concurrente députée sortante
de la majorité présidentielle
ce qu'on vit c'est la sympathique jeu
consciente que c'est un outil de
communication mais c'est un moment où on
sort de la crise on est en pleine guerre
et gens sont un peu aigri je trouvais
intéressant de pouvoir utiliser un combi
parce que c'est cool c'est baba cool et
il permet de la cepa titre simplement
quoi elle sait que dans sa
circonscription les gilets jaunes se
sont fait entendre en leur temps elle
veut en quelques semaines retisser le
lien entre citoyens et politiques et
pourquoi pas à la sortie des écoles
regarde
là on a tout prévu normalement c'est le
génie qui les mangent mais elle allait
elle va bien elle veut bien partager
comment vous l'expliquez vous êtes
fortement t national juste parce qu'il
ya une démobilisation de tout le monde
on est un peu la politique justement on
n'y croit plus quoi donc je peux vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui cette
circonscription elle est pris en étau
entre deux extrêmes gauches et droites
et que si effectivement on a un député
de gauche ou de droite il n'obtiendra
rien sur le territoire parce qu'il ne
fait pas partie de la majorité
présidentielle au contraire ce sera que
des politiques d'opposition est donc là
pour le territoire ça sera compliqué
dans ce duel contre le rn veronica
merrer veut jouer le front républicain
quand elle tombe sur les électeurs de la
nuque baisse
[Musique]
si jamais au deuxième tour je me
retrouve face à eddie jazz
sachant que bon moi je suis pas
quelqu'un d'extrême moi je suis
quelqu'un qui rassemble davantage vers
lauréats monsieur qui s'est présenté
dans mon lotissement avec effectivement
les tracts de cette dame oui que j'ai
refusé d'accord je le prends d'accord
voilà très bien ses mots ont fusé de
près si jamais je suis au deuxième tour
rachel wood diaz tombée hier soir oui
écoute et on verra bien treillières et
c'est surtout pour eux après oui vous
avez le maquereau ni si elle et elle est
amoureuse
les tiens regarde tu vois tu la regardes
sur le marché de blaye la députée
sortante va trouver un peu de soutien
vous
souhaitez
ne restez pas caché ou
c'est bien de venir marcher faut y aller
faut y aller faut y aller
elle tombe de parler d'avenir quitte à
en perdre son latin je me suis pour les
élections présidentielles si vous fait
jour en jour à manama maire
sortant c'est vous lucie moi d'accord qu
à la normale a put les dacquois la
revoilà les pays menacés reprenons la
renaissance redescendus voilà pourquoi
je mets la hache mais bon voilà
politique bonne
connaissance de toute la majorité là
nous aujourd'hui on va s'appeler
ensemble et ensuite donc c'est la
renaissance à plusieurs parties en fait
on est plusieurs parties merci merci
à mr jours
[Musique]
oui l'histoire
ok très bien qu'on va continuer un petit
peu bonjour madame rêve bon merci merci
il faut absolument un contre-pouvoir à
ce monsieur ce monsieur
écrasé de son bord cinq ans il faut
compter je sais pas lesquels mis en
lambeaux
[Musique]
le lendemain
samedi 9h séquence générosité dans le
village viticole de cubnezais
[Musique]
une association organise une marche de 5
km dont les bénéfices seront
redistribués à des réfugiés d'ukrainiens
[Musique]
sa personne
edwige diaz et ses équipes ont bien pris
soin de venir avec leurs tee shirt
floqué je vote edwige quand tout à coup
[Musique]
mais pas discrète
non elle n'est pas venue mais nous on va
marcher
mais la candidate et rennes n'est pas
femme à se laisser impressionner par mon
député
et elle réagit immédiatement pour se
fondre dans la masse
[Rires]
[Musique]
dispersion 10 personnes
elle manque pas de toupet parce que je
me sens il me semble quand même que les
députés européens ont voté contre les
subventions à l'ukraine au niveau de
l'europe donc le fait de vouloir aller
marcher avec ce type d'association je
trouve ça totalement antinomiques mais
c'est la politique politicienne de
madame diane
notre maire de perpignan louis aliot est
partie avec un but récupérer des
ukrainiens des réfugiés pour les
accueillir à perpignan donc aujourd'hui
oui nous sommes à cette marche de
l'ukraine en fait c'est tout à fait en
accord avec les valeurs que nous
défendons à l'issue du deuxième tour le
rm compte hier deux circonscriptions en
gironde
contre la députée sortante edwige diaz
l'emportent et contribue à faire de ce
scrutin un moment historique pour le
parti d'extrême droite
ouvrez vraie grosse surprise c'est le
nombre de députés rassemblement national
qui ont été élues c'est très
impressionnant de l'ordre de 90 députés
rassemblement national c'est très
important est sans aucun doute que nous
avons franchi et bien le dimanche 19
juin 2022 nous avons franchi une étape
très importante dans notre vie politique
pour stabiliser le rassemblement
national comme un pilier de la vie
démocratique leur assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui récolte clairement les
fruits d'une stratégie de maillage
territorial très important quand vous
regardez le résultat de marine le pen au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en 2022 elle arrive en
tête dans vingt mille communes dans plus
de vingt mille communes vous avez en
france 34 mille communes ce qui signifie
que leur assemblée nationale n'a plus de
zones territoriales où il est vraiment
faiblesse marine le pen fait beaucoup
moins peur que jean marie le pen et fait
même moins peur que jean luc mélenchon
il n'empêche dans 270 circonscription le
deuxième tour s'est soldée par un duel
entre la nuque mais c'est la macro ni
notre regard s'est porté en essonne
mesdames messieurs je vous souhaite la
bienvenue dans votre salle des mariages
concentrez-vous à prendre pour époux
monsieur sébastien emmanuel or ce qui
ici présents
je vous souhaite tout ce qui est mieux
pour vous on peut vous les abordez vous
nadia carcasse et adjointe au maire de
sainte geneviève des bois s'est lancé
pour la première fois dans la course des
législatives
sa mission conserver cette
circonscription dans le giron de la
majorité présidentielle est pour elle
les électeurs devraient être cohérent je
pense qu' il aime bien il ya un
président qui est qui est élu pour cinq
ans et là il faut il faut qu'il puisse
gouverner pays et pour pouvoir gouverner
ce pays sereinement on se doit d'aller
lui donner une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale
la 10e circonscription de l'essonne
c'est à la fois sainte geneviève des
bois et ses petits pavillons
et la grande borne à grigny la ville la
plus pauvre de france
tous les samedis nadia carcasse est fait
campagne sur un marché de ce quartier
résidentiel
mais en ce week-end de l'ascension
il n'y a pas foule
on la semaine prochaine ça va reprendre
il n'y a pas de raison la candidate à un
argument évident pour inciter les
électeurs à voter pour elle
je pense le néerlandais mais bon il a eu
à me rappeler deux ans que ville et en
ukraine une crise sociale avait causé
les jaunes je pense que c'est un bilan
sur cinq ans qui a été perturbée
sur le fond du projet elle reste très
vague et surtout se veut sans doctrine
[Musique]
la porte
elle fait une campagne d'élu local
[Musique]
sa fille on va l'appeler à nice
la dame
à prendre de ses nouvelles et puis si
elle a besoin
elle met en avant son bilan d'adjointe
au maire il a mise en place d'un
vaccinodromes géant avec une méthode
très macro nist on s'est battu pour
avoir le centre de vaccination sur sur
la grille de sainte geneviève des bois
pour les habitants du territoire et on
est très fier aujourd'hui d'avoir
vacciné plus de 400 mais perdent tous
les gens du coin ont été vaccinées grâce
à elle
face à un argument choc ben je pense que
c'est un argument choc mais parce qu'on
a mis on a mis en baba tous les clivages
politiques on a mis tous les
corporatismes par terre et on s'est
retroussé les manches qu'on soit de
gauche qu'on soit de droite qu'on soit
médecin consommait infirmières pour sa
formation
l'équipe m'a cronista une intuition elle
aura le soutien des plus de 60 ans face
au candidat de la new tech la conscience
ou miser mélenchon c'est l'épouvantail
pour les gens âgés ah oui ici
dans mes clients fin les gens ils
veulent surtout pas né un jour et
pourquoi pour les gens âgés entre parce
que c'est des idées complètement
farfelue il est anti européen
[Musique]
tarde de voir les résultats là ça va
savall étonné la france a soumis ce
n'est pas crédible pour vous non non pas
du tout pas du tout du tout
cdc comme on dit en jargon des fouteurs
de merde
le candidat ainsi nomi
l'opposant mélenchonistes à la
représentante de la majorité
présidentielle s'appelle antoine les au
mans
[Musique]
tractage à la grande borne la cité degré
mis un triangle de 4000 logements coincé
entre les autoroutes et la maison
d'arrêt de fleury mérogis
donc c'est moi qui suis candidat pour
être jeune et puis rappelle antoine
voyez c'est moi à côté de mélenchon
c'est moi même si j'ai même si j'ai bon
bah
merci beaucoup bonne soirée
c'est moi
un tractage
avec un appui de taille
tu vas bien philippe riou travail super
le maire communiste de grigny c'est pour
les élections tout simplement le
meilleur maire du monde en 2021
on va passer selon la city meilleures
fondations une organisation londonienne
on avait envoyé mélangeant merlen pays à
la présidentielle mais avec ces
élections là encore
lui c'est le candidat pour qu'il soit
notre député soutenu par jean luc
mélenchon on a besoin d'avoir un député
qui soit avec nous qui nous aident enfin
il n'y a pas une foi qui doit manquer si
vous voulez voter pour moi ont voté pour
jean luc mélenchon et antoine méo main
ils seraient entrés très gros comme sa
levée vous pouvez pas le rater
à bientôt
eh ben c'est normal
merci
et les combats pour la population n'ont
pas été portées depuis extrêmement
longtemps par par le par les députés qui
se sont succédé que ce soit malek boutih
ou pierre allard à fond de la majorité
les deux d'ailleurs dans les majorités
présidentielles malek boutih dans la
majorité de françois hollande pierre
allard a faim dans la majorité de
emmanuel macron
dans l'adversité où le silence or on a
besoin de changer des choses ici
monsieur lui ces futurs députés
bonjour
tu vois ta belle visite 1
j'ai pas dire deux fois
bah oui j'ai tous les collèges à la cave
et remet à gagner les campagnes non sens
bien je suis si son style avant la
gagner des compagnies enfin on aura un
député avec nous ça va être bien ça va
aider pour grigny
ça va être bien
à bientôt pour toi merci merci nous
avons rouvert sa merci
merci il a dit bon courage
un porte à porte pour que la résignation
se transforme en vote
la présélection prend des allures de
lutte des classes ouais un peu ouais bah
c'est bien on est tourné vers ce moment
politique
on est dans ce moment politique donc oui
un bloc populaire il faut que ce bloc
populaire deviennent majoritaires dans
ce pays pour que nos vies et changer
donc oui c'est une lutte des classes
un de voeux une photo pour les réseaux
forcément car en toile et hautmont est
un candidat aux législatives un peu
particulier pour l efi
les yeux toujours rivés sur un écran il
est le monsieur réseaux sociaux du
mouvement à 33 ans cela fait presque une
vente qu'il est employé au siège du
parti bonjour
il y est arrivé en 2013 alors étudiant
en sciences politiques
quand j'ai commencé on n'était pas
beaucoup en effet une petite équipe et
on était les durs de durs convaincu de
deux des idées de jean luc mélenchon est
qui qui portait avec moi c'est un
bouquin qui m'a convaincu c'est un
bouquin qui s'appelle qu'ils s'en
aillent tous il m'a convaincu de
rejoindre ensuite j'ai vu que j'étais en
accord et qu en toi liés au mans a fait
du vétéran de la présidentielle un pro
des réseaux tous les lundis il tourne
les vidéos de jean luc mélenchon qui
font son succès sur twitter tik tok et
les autres
youtube la même récompense est
[Musique]
le prochain ces deux millions
le tribun aux envolées lyriques s'est
converti à la com politique version 21e
siècle pour mieux faire campagne
c'est la partie des gens qui vous disent
il était mieux avant je plaisante dit
avant j étais pas mieux donc
la dernière où je me suis servi ces tic
toc
que j'adore le tictoc c'est un mode
d'expression faut le prendre comme pour
ce que c'est si c'était de la peinture
c'est de la peinture si c'est de la
musique c'est plat mais les critiques
toi qui lui dicte au bout vous n'allez
pas faire du youtube à tik tok voilà
c'est un art x
propose bien un poste bien ça parfait
ah oui tu m'as bien avec moi à mes
regrets ça comme je suis avachi regarde
on peut aborder par marina voir moi je
suis de l'école du matérialisme
historique du sud marxiste ce pas son
cas et puis bon resserrement parle en
travaillant en lisant en discutant comme
ça qu'on baril et toc et c'est un homme
qui est très construit
intellectuellement bon c'est bon vieux
prof qui me préparer tout ça
mais vous convient maintenant après pour
vous répondre aussi il ya la partie
programmée c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi
l'attachement un individu et au final si
on en est là où on en est aujourd'hui
c'est aussi parce que tu as su porter
une ligne politique un peu envers et
contre tout parce que si on avait écouté
ce qu'ils nous disaient que c'était
impossible qu'on n'y arriverait pas que
voilà on n'aurait rien fait or on a
réussi à le faire et c'est parce qu'on a
réussi à imposer un rapport de force de
la dimension qu'on a imposé que
aujourd'hui on est tous ensemble autour
d'un programme
au terme de la campagne en toile et au
mans bat nadia carcasse est avec 55% des
suffrages
oui le duel entre les manuels macron et
jean luc mélenchon bien évidemment a eu
lieu l'un comme l'autre jean luc
mélenchon emmanuel macron en fin de
campagne en particulier non plus retenu
leurs coûts il s'agissait de polariser
il s'agissait de montrer que l'autre
était l'ennemi absolu duels il ya eu
mais bon finalement le prix zone la
république a été très peu présents lors
de cette campagne donc pour qu'il y ait
duel il faut que les deux joueurs
acceptent de jouer la vérité c'est que
j'ai huit matchs ont été très présents
emmanuel macron été très absent au
moment des législatives c'est la
question de la doctrine c'est la
question de la clarté de la doctrine et
du coût des mesures et c'est ça qu'a
pays aussi la majorité c'est une
doctrine insuffisamment précises la
france insoumise tout le monde
comprenait et savait ce qu'elle
proposait en revanche la doctrine depuis
le début du quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron elle est plus floue aux yeux des
français
une gauche unie en apparence seulement
las nubes a dû faire face à une
véritable fronde en occitanie en
particulier un samedi de marcher à
prayssac dans le lot
jadis quand
on est vieux on est discipliné 10 est au
courant de tout ce
ledit dissidents et rémi branco
ancien socialiste proche de stéphane le
foll et poli par la pasionaria de la
social-démocratie carole delga
présidente de région n'ont investi par
la nuit baisse rémi branco compte sur
son ancrage local
moi j'ai pas le sentiment de changer
peut-être que d'autres charges moi je
suis fidèle à mes convictions donc donc
je suis ils apprennent qu'ils sont
dissidents à leur histoire dissidents à
leur engagement moi je suis fidèle à ses
engagements
dans sa seule région
carole delga soutien en quatorze
candidats dissidents de gauche dans
toute la france ils sont ainsi 60 à se
présenter avec l'appui de françois
hollande dont bernard cazeneuve pour eux
la corne du ps serait trop floue
il ya de nombreux sujets où il est écrit
que ça sera la sagesse des
parlementaires donc moi quand je
soutiens candidat quand je ne suis qu'un
projet c'est en connaissance de cause
donc moi je souhaite avoir des positions
très claires les candidats aux
législatives sur la question de la lutte
contre le communautarisme sur la
question de la relation avec
l'entreprise sur la question européenne
et leurs discours paraît séduire
assez gentil merci
franchement
on
va bientôt merci
rémi branco est sûr de son fait à l'aise
sur le fond comme sur la forme je pense
qu'à pâques ni gauche il ya toujours des
sensibilités différentes il faut qu'au
premier tour on choisit ce et au
deuxième tour par contre on s'unit pour
battre la droite a toujours été comme ça
il était rare gagner comme ça hollande a
gagné comme ça carole delga né comme ça
et demain aux législatives je vais
gagner comme ça il y croit d'autant que
le parti présidentiel n'a pas investi
deux candidats ici
[Musique]
au contraire rémi branco on pourrait
bien bénéficier de l'électorat macro
nist
la candidate de l'union de la gauche
la voilà l'insoumise est là bouchard
ex ingénieur devenu professeur des
écoles
elle juge qu'on ait fait le dissident
n'est vraiment pas dans ce grand
monsieur ben cohen un programme
qui est celui du gps
qui pour moi n'a jamais marché jusque là
et je pense que le signal des électeurs
étaient très claires au soir des
présidentielles et je trouve surtout
dommage de ne pas tenir compte de ce
message à 10km de cahors pradines le
genre d'endroit où on est un peu à
l'écart de tout vote pour les élections
mais c'est jean luc mélenchon
tiens je tue lui sert à quoi de la
partie on se croisait
et vous vous allez y aller pour les
législatives
elsa bougeard rencontre surtout des
dégoûtés de la politique
ceux là même qui se sentent abandonnés
voilà vous êtes vous qu on fait des
élections mme hadja le temps qu'il y
aura des choses qui changeront pas c'est
fou ce que machin je ferai pas
c'est à dire qu'est ce que vous attendez
qu'ils changent
ducrocq déménagement est pour nous le
vote n'est pas une solution de dire
justement va choisir des mots voter pour
des gens qui veulent corriger ça et
c'est ça peut pas être une issue non
mais nous ce qu'on propose dans
l'immédiat et promettre des bureaux de
poste retrouver trésor public pour un
pôle emploi etc et ça fait aussi partie
de cette vie de quartier d'avoir sa
surface et surtout quand pulsion il y
avait quand même la poste avec un tel
que tout
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard il n'ira
probablement pas voter comme plus de la
moitié des français
à l'issue du premier tour le dissident
rémi branco est d'éliminer face à la
droite c'était là bouchard qui
représente la gauche au second tour la
dissidence n'a pas fait recette
ça n'a pas pris à hauteur des espérances
carole delga envisagé sans aucun doute
quelque chose de beaucoup plus important
de manière à pouvoir peser après les
élections législatives et peut-être de
s'adresser à ses camarades socialistes
en leur disant va regarder on peut aussi
arriver sans eux on a très vite pu
mesurer que le fait que ce soit france a
soumis en écologie soit socialiste en
réalité jouer assez peu alors que
certains pensaient que quand c'était un
candidat france insoumise il y aurait du
côté d'une partie de la gauche une forte
répulsion mais dans la réalité les
dissidents très peu pesé cinq ans c'est
très long on va voir à quel moment se
délient tous ceux ou sous explose ou
éclater le cartel commun qui aujourd'hui
existe et qui a permis pour part à une
partie importante évidemment de la
gauche de rentrée à l'assemblée
nationale
dans cette partie du lot une fois le
dissident éliminé elsa bougeard affronte
le député sortant l air
aurélien pradié le numéro trois du parti
figure montante de la droite ça va
du sénat et ce jour là il a un soutien
de poids gérard larcher
aurélien pradié a ravi le siège à la
gauche il ya cinq ans et il dépense
beaucoup d'énergie pour le conserver
[Musique]
c'est quand même
c'était dur en 2010 est aussi c'était
extrêmement favorable les deux choses
sont totalement déconnectés
mais sur le marché de cahors dix
opposants se font entendre
[Musique]
mais ça
le député veut rassurer son électorat de
droite et rappelé ses fondamentaux
bonjour vous allez bien nous avons pensé
à l'hôtellerie oui je l'espère gesa n'y
a personne en gt avec coeur les
épandeurs il s'agira du tout j'étais
avec lionel marceau la semaine dernière
que nous pouvons sur la bonjour on se
bat sur ça c'est dramatique dramatique
on a quand même un sujet de la relation
travail ou pas puisque les gens veulent
pas y aller et je me disais de l'autre
côté on a quand même attention il ne
travaille pas
on n'aura pas réglé ça n'aura rien du
coup de rabot
si l'ambiance est bon enfant
[Musique]
ils républicains craignent un score
catastrophique pour ces législatives
imaginez que l'opposition ne soit
incarné que par la france 1 soumises ou
par le rassemblement national ce qui ne
manquera pas quelque chose de très
profonde démocratie
à l'issue du second tour aurélien pradié
a été lu face à elsa bougeard
et les résultats au niveau national son
meilleur que redouté
c'est presque une divine surprise pour
les républicains de se retrouver avec un
groupe parlementaire qui n'est pas
divisée par deux et il ne faudrait pas
qu'on raconte des histoires sur les
l'air sont en réalité très puissant
parce qu'ils sont indispensables à une
majorité
la dynamique dans l'opinion dlr est une
dynamique de croissance continue depuis
2007 ou à minima de windows
il est des territoires où les votes sont
presqu'à qui haït manuel macron la 4e
circonscription des yvelines
bonjour est ce que vous êtes de chatou
alors vous savez c'est pour les
élections du stade cible mais je vous
connais oui j'avais écouté fait des
petits alors voilà exactement exactement
je vous remercie il n'était pas ça c'est
le petit bilan de mandat
exactement à un endroit on aime parler
politique avec sa députée
c'est fondamental mais après
je pas sûr que le choix d'elisabeth horn
et celle d'être le premier ressort de
nommer au site à machin je pense que
c'est un machin à des mineurs une image
un peu pataugé dans la semoule
bon en tout cas à bientôt et merci
beaucoup merci
bonjour et skoda de chatou par hasard
merci bonjour
ya eu quand même pas mal d'attentes sur
un marché puis encore qu'ils sont
vraiment
pas qu'ils ont ministre qu'est ce que la
pression dans non mais fin 2010 que
tenir le diamant et ça fait chier ça
s'arrête jamais en fait c'était le
nouveau monde est en fait si
la déception est magnifique on amuse
autant qu'ils sont moi mais
c'est ce que mon nom mais voilà je suis
pas forcément d'accord et oui après je
trouve que c'est intéressant d'avoir une
bonne vue parce que c'est aussi nous
dire qu'est ce que nous améliorer
on va à venir
au fil de la campagne les sondages sont
de moins en moins bon pour la majorité
présidentielle
circonscription n'est pas forcément le
reflet du reste de la france mais moi en
tout cas ici j'entends beaucoup ce
discours de légitimité
moi je peins je crois qu'on se bat pour
avoir la majorité et j'envisage pas une
seconde qu'on n'ait pas la même heure
était venue
la campagne se durcit au niveau national
alors même en territoire conquis marie
lebey tu ne se prive pas de la notoriété
d'un ministre pour son porte-à-porte
même temps en train de nettoyer les
panneaux
étaient recouverts
c du collège de basse là
bonjour
et coup d'envoi carrière sur scène c'est
lui qui en 2007 avait plutôt bien voter
pour nous on a fait 52 % correspond donc
voilà ah oui tu en viens on va faire les
maisons
et avec un ministre tout juste reconduit
il accompagne devient un plaidoyer pour
l'avenir plus qu'un bilan du quinquennat
[Musique]
et la stabilité sympa sinon mes frères
c'est la côte est déroulée derrière pour
les élections à projets doit être
pouvoir d'achat augmenter de 2 % des
retraités il était temps de prendre un
dysfonctionnement on va maintenir le
bouclier d'ariza sur l'énergie je
soutiens je soutiens nous avons élu
parce que sinon il faut pas travailler
correctement
et il sait y faire l'ex ministre de la
santé ya fait
[Musique]
vous êtes déjà convaincus qu'ils
allaient voter pour barry est évidemment
non mais de toute façon on va voter pour
lui forcément négligée on va pas laisser
mélenchon battait première ligne
en ce lundi de pentecôte
olivier verrons a sillonné quatre
circonscriptions pour soutenir des
candidats à maquereau nist
insolite façon de faire campagne parfois
pour marie le bec avec ce qu'on appelle
un dîner appart compreniez elle connaît
son autre qui a choisi des habitants de
toute obédience pourrait changer en
petit comité
l'agression à être livrés et sympathique
l'idée étant que j'ai faire aussi des
remontées qui moi me sont utiles
sur ce que vous avez perçu du mandat
précédent ce que vous espérez pour pour
le suivant etc
les gens dans leurs impôts payent des
services publics auxquels ils n'ont plus
accès on est à 20 km paris je parle même
pas de la creuse je parle pas de mes en
banlieue parisienne vainqueur de paris
on a envie qu à se soigner correctement
je trouve qu'on fait un espèce de nos
thèmes de dire on peut pas forcer les
professionnels de santé à s'installer
pas moi ça me choquerait pas qu'on dise
fondamentalement on fait comme pour les
pharmacies et il faut ce qui est des
professionnels de santé pour 2500
habitants en fait qu'ils le veuillent ou
non moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui on n'a
pas de planification suffisante
delà de la formation en fonction des
durées des jobs si on veut pas tenta de
jeunes qui se précipitent en staps droit
ou psycho sociaux et que bah finalement
on et magnin peut enfin mon dissémine ça
un peu plus sur les filières je crois
juste qu'il faut montrer la diversité
mais le président a replica dit on va
faire des erreurs d'orientation
supplémentaire à l'école ya de moins en
moins d'artisans de tpe qui embauchent
ou qui recrutent ils ont vraiment peur
du droit du travail et des conséquences
du dire le marché du travail est trop
lourd trop compliqué ok mais est ce que
ton objectif s'est pas d'abord de
développer ta boîte et si ça passe par
un recrutement c'est intéressant de le
faire tu as un peu déçu qu'on n'ait pas
été au bout de la réforme des retraites
et surtout j'ai passé quinze jours
d'enfer en hémicycle avec les insoumis
nous hurlant dessus pour défendre
toujours les mêmes amendement donc voilà
donc c'est à dire un peu ce sentiment ne
pas avoir été au bout de ce qu'on était
capable de faire plus que quelques jours
pour que ses invités la prêche la bonne
parole dans leur entourage
[Applaudissements]
marie le bec a été réélu largement face
à la candidate de la nuque baisse mais
aussi face aux représentants des
républicains éliminée dès le premier
tour
l'opposant a l'air de marie le bec
aux jambes mais barack sens c'est le
médiatique charles consigny
et il mène campagne pour la première
fois
[Musique]
alors après je fais des gens que je
ressens captifs lui je sens pas très
captif
cfpc
la cftc ca votent à droite et cheveux
d'une droite raisonnable la constante du
quinquennat macro c'est de vous dire que
vous n'avez pas d'autre choix que d'être
d'accord avec lui soit vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que chez makro et vous
êtes quelqu'un de raisonnable de
formidables qui aime ses enfants et qui
est honnête soit vous avez des critiques
à faire et dans ces cas là vous êtes un
extrémiste un fasciste un anti vague un
complotiste et tout ce que vous voulez
donc un coup il nous fait le coup du
père il brun pour les élections
législatives il nous fait celui du péril
rouge et on n'a pas le droit de ne pas
être d'accord bas je suis désolé moi je
suis pas d'accord avec ça et je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup d'électeurs qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec ça beaucoup
d'électeurs sont tout simplement
indifférents
bonjour madame est ce que vous allez
voter aux élections législatives vous
pouvez encore changer d'avis
on se raconte des histoires comme quoi
nous serions un peuple épris politique
sans voir que des pans entiers se
détournent de la politique se désengage
il ya un élément important qui et
comment reconnecter une partie des gens
aussi à la chose publique comment
reconnecter une partie des gens à la
chose démocratique et à l'intérêt de la
politique publique rappelons nous quand
même beaucoup ces images que nous avons
vues au moment de la crise des gilet
jaune avec des français qui hurlent au
visage de notre classe politique
pourquoi je galère alors que je
travaille on aimerait bien savoir ce que
la nouvelle assemblée nationale va avoir
à dire nous n'avons pas les moyens de
nous permettre une deuxième crise et
gilet jaune
on palais bourbon le groupe de la
majorité présidentielle va devoir
composer
comment
le nouveau visage de l'assemblée
nationale promet des débats enflammés et
des rapports de force complexe
peut-être des alliances inattendues
[Musique]
à chaque député à chaque groupe à chaque
parti de se réinventer pour faire vivre
la démocratie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]